good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the mid-suffolk district
council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council and i'm
chairing this meeting today
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all
times
unless you are sitting down
or are exempt from doing so and that you
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversation while
others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we will be using e-voting for
this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully
excluded now move to the agenda please
item one apologies for absence
good morning chair we have received
apologies from councillor brewster
thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare
cancer
council
council richardson thank you chair um i
think i'd better declare a non-pecuniary
interest for gender item eight paper mca
2125 as one of the stillbirds is within
my ward
thank you councillor richardson
councillor whitehead yeah in item 10
there are some minor items of benefit to
gateway 14 i'm a gateway 14 board
director but it's a non-community
interest
thank you
item 3 mca
21-24 to confirm the minutes of the
cabinet meeting held on 4th of october
2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
could i have a proposal please counselor
heading
and can i have a second to please
council gaut thank you the governance
officer will now conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app if you scroll down
to the blue line
counselor bern i
are you able to vote on the appointment
verbally please
chair there's eight books for
thank you very much
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with council's
petition scheme
none received chan
item five questions by councillors
none received jam
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
there are no matters referred
thank you
item seven forthcoming decisions list
does anybody have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list
no thank you
item eight
mca
21
one
is the community infrastructure levy
the seal expenditure program for
november 2021
and i'm now going to invite the cabinet
member for planning to introduce the
report
thank you very much jim um
yes thank you paper mca
2125 provides you with the sill
expenditure program
there are two decisions for cabinet
today
the first is a significant bid for just
over 1.5 million
towards the expansion of elmswell
primary school
the money will be used to increase
capacity of the school from
315 places to 420
to accommodate the increased population
associated with current housing
development in the village
officers have clearly put a lot of work
into considering what are quite complex
issues and i welcome the detail provided
at appendix d
in short we have the education authority
enacting their strategy for increasing
primary school prices in the village
we also have strong concerns expressed
by parish ward and county councillors
that the long-term solution for the
village should be a new larger primary
school
to accommodate longer-term potential
future growth
there is much to think through here and
i hope that the reports are clear enough
for you
the second matter is more
straightforward
when we approved the bid for thurston
community college to provide funding
towards the purchase of playing fields
this was phase one of a three-phase
project
and when we did that we also sought to
protect to preempt the latter phases
by requiring the completion of a
community user agreement
as a condition of our funding
phase two will enable school capacity to
increase from uh 1500 to 1650
pupils
phase three will provide a synthetic
turf pitch
which is the element that would be
expected to provide for community use
out of school hours
this phase is currently under review
therefore the recommendation is to
remove the requirement for the community
user agreement from the current funding
and only require it when phase three of
the project comes forward
whilst i appreciate this has been a
little long as an introduction already
i do not think it should try to explain
the whole of either matter
the report addresses them with
appendices b and d providing significant
additional detail
and i therefore move the recommendation
and look for a
second i'm joined by tom barker today
and joanne fellowes suffolk county
council's
schools infrastructure program manager
and pete mumford their school's planning
manager if you have any questions
thank you
thank you councillor do i have a
secondary
counselor fleming i'm happy to second
the proposal thank you thank you very
much
i'm now going to invite councillor geek
who is the ward member for elmswell to
make a representation to the cabinet
councillor geek
thank you chad do i have to stand up
excellent thank you
i'd first like to uh reiterate that the
parish council and both ward members and
the uh county councillor are all against
the proposal the parish council have
sought the support of our mp joe
churchill to fight the proposal and
although her reply has been somewhat
gnomic they have been assured that she's
raising the matter with michael gove so
all the villages elected representatives
from top to bottom appear to be against
spending public money in this way
elmsworld primary school was built in
the early 1970s for 210 four to nine
year olds following the school
organizational review it was expanded to
take 315 pupils up to 11 years old today
county council figures estimate 332
primary age pupils living in the village
but luckily only
277 of them are currently forecast to
choose elmsweil primary school so there
are still plenty of spaces and delaying
this decision will not prevent local
children attending the school this
current school's physical space is now
quoted as 1.6 hectares a little smaller
than the minimum size for a 420 place
school but this includes the substantial
protected tree belt around two sides
which although lovely takes up a lot of
space we don't seem to have a figure for
the space minus the trees but as you can
see from the plan as you have seen from
the plan they take up about a quarter of
the site so the land available for
school use is probably in the region of
1.2 hectares and that's only just over
half what's normally needed but i'm not
here to argue that this restricted site
is too small for the proposal although
clearly that is true my main argument is
that it's a waste of public funds as the
school will again be outgrown in a few
years and that there are better sites to
focus on and invest in
housing developments that have already
been granted planning permission in
elmswell or that have been allocated in
the jlp will enormously increase the
number of households in the village and
there are at least two more proposed
developments not on jlp allocated sites
that we know about and of course there
are likely to be further windfall sites
the growth is foreseeable but the school
will not be able to expand further and
we will need a new school so that's an
awful lot of money to spend on enlarging
the school to give a bare minimum of
provision that would be just about
acceptable for a few years
now you may argue that some elmsweil
children can simply attend school in
woolpit where there's a plot of land
available for a new school but there's
no guarantee that that new school will
actually happen the much wanted cycle
path which will allow sustainable travel
over the a14 to wallpaper is even less
likely to materialize in time as it
requires funding from developments that
are a long way in the future and over
which we have no control
in addition on the 20th of october the
issue of primary education in elmswell
and woolpit was raised in the joint
local plan hearings as being a matter on
which more information was needed
so why not try to plan a bit further
ahead and build a new school now there
are two potential sites for a new school
in the village both of which are
comfortably large this may require more
investment in the short term but it will
be better value for money in the long
term the parish council have offered
some financial support to our brand new
school so they are prepared to invest
surely mid-suffolk should also be
investing for the future of our
communities and to use councillor
mansell's words please think very
carefully about voting for this sill
funding to go ahead is it what is best
for our communities and is it good value
for money
why not have a short breathing space
reconsider as the joint local plan
inspector has suggested and make sure
that the decision taken is the right one
thank you
thank you councillor geek
as councillor berner's already indicated
we have with us joanna fellows who's the
suffolk county council schools
infrastructure program manager welcome
and also pete mumford
uh county council schools planning
manager
to
help respond to members questions
welcome both of you
do we have any
questions from
cabinet members
councillor hattie
thank you um yes but i would like to
know what your response to um to
councillor geek on behalf of um
councillor mansell's um
basically thoughts are you know how do
you feel replying to um the parish
council and the district councillor and
the county councillor on their thoughts
so i can deal with the detail about the
site size um which we've already talked
through um through the planning
application process so the proposal
already has planning approval
yeah and so we talked through the site
size then it is it is correct that there
is a large tree belt around but the
school do use this they see this as an
important resource on their school site
and whilst you know it
it's not
um it's not playing field they use it
creatively for um
for forest schools and for um
educational purposes
the scheme also is providing a multi-use
games area so an all-weather pitch
sorry to interrupt you you're not really
answering what i actually meant well i
can see what you've done and what you
put bit bits why not why not do
something bigger you know what what is
your answer to um
spending money now and it could spend
you know have a different location that
wouldn't be banned by trees i think
that's over to
pete we go thank you very much good
morning everyone um
the issue we have um in there as well is
we don't have a site available to us to
build a new school on we've never as an
educational authority been offered a new
site in the village
and as such we are limited in what we
can do in in the village so expanding
the school because they will be over
capacity in our forecasting data by
september of this year
or sorry of 2022 expanding the school is
is the option that is available to us
and that we have um built our strategy
upon there is also obviously the
connectivity with wool pit
and the fact that we have a new housing
development in the village that has been
proposed that has offered us a new
school site so our strategy has been
developed based on a new school in wall
pit that will not only serve the housing
and the and the overcapacity issues we
have there but also to assist in any
over subscription that we may find we
have you know as well in future years as
well
now at the moment we are looking at
forecasts that are based on information
available to us at the moment these
forecasts do change they they change
um over over the time over the period
that we're talking about we've seen a
decrease for instance in primary age
population in the last few years that's
quite a cyclical thing it's something we
do see quite a lot of that may change in
the future as well we're continually
monitoring that information to see
what we would do in terms of
putting that new schooling warp in place
when it becomes available to us the land
there and how that impacts on onto elves
well but
the fact of the matter is realistic
realistically for us is when we
responded to the local plan information
our strategy was was built on the fact
we had a school site offered to us in
orbit we did not have a school site
offered to us in elswell and so by
expanding ellswell for this september
allows us to meet the needs of the
village for the next few years until
that new school in warp then comes in
apologies apologies
um so i just wonder if um counselor
melon has because i was under the um
impression from councillor mansell that
there had been i'm not saying that
they've been you know
quite you know
qualified sites but there was several
sites that that could be considered for
a school in emswell and what are you
basically saying when amsoil is full we
expect people to take the children to
woolpit
the first time i've used this microphone
to apologize and i will try and speak up
apologies um
yes we we are aware that there has been
mention of other sites that are
available in the village as i say as an
educational authority we've not been
offered those sites so we've not been
able to look at them in terms of whether
they are appropriate to to build a new
school
and actually whether that is a sensible
strategy given the number of pupils that
might be coming from the housing because
when we're talking about a new school
development of a new school it needs to
be sustainable you need to have a
quantum of pupils to be able to attend
the school to make it sustainable so
having
two smallish schools
in in one village
might be a concern for us in terms of
sustainability so one option might be if
there were a site available to us for us
to relocate the existing school and
expand it at the same time now that's
something that you know we have
considered in other areas we've actually
done recently in thurston itself however
it's based on the availability of a land
size large enough for us to do that
which we are not aware of and we've
never been consulted on and similarly
the cost to relocate the existing places
would have to be found from somewhere
because it can't be sealed it can't be
section 106 because you're reproviding
rather than providing new places so
again there's there's a significant
amount of funding probably
a rough estimate four or five million
pounds at least that would need to be
found from somewhere to relocate those
existing places
sorry my other part of the question was
are you expecting the overflow just to
go to woolpit
yes absolutely if there are
additional pupils in elmswell coming
from housing and again that's from
housing that's not yet been approved so
it doesn't feature currently in our
forecasts but our strategy is based on
if there are pupils that would then need
places above and beyond what elsewhere
can currently have capacity for the new
school in wall pit would be where we
would be expecting those pupils to go
but that is predicated on the new cycle
way and pathway being in place for us to
safely allow children to do that and
there are pupils already going from from
village to village at the moment around
35 to 40 pupils go either way attending
wallpaper from elsewhere and vice versa
as well so there is that that
connectivity of travel currently at the
moment as well
i think it just just to expand on
councillor hadingham's point a little
bit
when you say you haven't considered
sites that have not come forward
for planning
because obviously you have no knowledge
of those
can you confirm that you have included
sites in within our emerging local plan
all the sites that we have been
made aware of in the local plan yes we
we have taken those into account my
understanding is some of the sites that
have been talked about is in terms of
being made available to us
aren't in that particular process at the
moment so as i say they've not been
they've not come to us usually any new
development would come to educational
authority obviously to their mitigate in
terms of our education strategy there
have been no sites that have come to us
that have offered us a a
a
piece of land large enough to mitigate a
new school in in helmsworld itself
thank you council burn
yes
thank you um
i'm interested in the the
timings of of these proposals
um you said a few minutes ago uh that
did take
um
some years for for the
increased uh
school the extended school in elmswell
um to to reach capacity
um
first question is um have you any
estimate i mean i know it's a bit of a
piece of string
question but any estimate of how long
that's likely to take
with the at the present rate of
of growth given that um
elbsworld has
uh taken i think most of the growth that
it was expected to or will be expected
to
and then after that i'd be interested to
know how long
uh it will uh correct me if i'm wrong
but i think that at presently the wool
pit school is
um under populated
so there is a time lapse there for that
for that to be um to to reach full
capacity before
um a
further provision has yet to be made so
the time that it takes for for elmswell
primary school to become full
then
uh it could be a shorter time actually
when when the wool pit primary school is
expected to be full but if it were not
then overspill from elmswell would then
have to go to woolpit
um and and then
i'm trying to get a sense of
when the new school
in woolpid or proposed new school in
woolpit would have to come online as it
were any any possibility of giving me
answers to those various questions
i'll do my very best um
timing is is a critical one in school
place planning it's it's um something
that we
we pour over
regularly around timings of of when new
schools need to be built when when
schools need to be expanded as i say it
can be a changing picture as we go
because we can only base our our
information on
four years worth of data because
otherwise the children aren't born who
would be going to the school so there is
an element as you move towards the end
of the forecasting period of five years
that we use where it gets a little more
difficult to be able to make those sorts
of predictions at the moment the
forecasting data is telling us the the
school in ellswell would reach capacity
by around 2025. so in september 2025 our
current forecasts show us that that
school would be would be over capacity
now in terms of wall pit itself
our understanding and what we're basing
our strategy on at the time when when we
developed the strategy in response to
the local plan is that the the new
school in wall pit would be available or
the new school site in wall pathologies
would be available to us within that
time frame so we would be able to then
build the new school in warpit to be
able to mitigate um not just the demand
in walpit itself but to be able to
manage the over subscription that we
would then be seeing in elm as well as
well now as i say that's that's the the
response that's what our strategy has
been based upon we are currently working
on as i say our forecasting on a yearly
basis almost six months actually in
in terms of just making sure that we
know what that current proposal is going
to be and whether that's going to be
what actually happens on the ground your
right wall pit at the moment does have
some spare capacity that's again borne
out by the fact that there has been a
lower
primary age population birth rate
currently but it's also been because of
um offset inspection judgments at the
school as well which is which has meant
that the school hasn't necessarily
attracted as many pupils as it has in
the past and we know in school place
planning these things can change quite
quickly and actually you might see the
school improve itself over a short
period and actually attract a lot more
pupils back so it's
it's not one that i can really say with
any certainty unfortunately in terms of
time scales but our strategy at the
outset was was built upon
us having the new school site in the
wall pit able to be able to build a new
school in time for the needs of
elsewhere as well
may come back please um
okay thank you thank you for that
hypothetical now because it's a what-if
type question
um
had there been a site available to
elmswell
um
have you any reason for for thinking
that our school in in woolpit would be
any
it would be a better location than shall
we say a school in elbsville had there
been a site available to you
that's a very good question and my
answer would be that we base our
strategies on what's available to us at
that given time when we developed our
strategy for ellswell and wall pit
together the land was given to us or
sorry it was available to us in in wall
pit that was that was um part of that
local plan provision and as i said
earlier there was no provision in there
as well had it been the other way around
absolutely we would have considered it
it's right and proper that we do because
actually had there been a site and then
was well and not one in war but we might
be in the same position we might be
talking um around around those issues
but but in reverse so
absolutely if there hadn't been a site
available to us as part of those local
plan developments in elmsworld we would
have certainly considered that now
whether we would have built both schools
is highly unlikely i don't think there
is enough provision in both villages to
require two new schools
but certainly if it had been that there
was land available in them as well and
not wall pit at that point then yes we
would have certainly considered that as
our as our strategy
so
final question then is how practicable
would it be at this stage of the game to
change the idea of building in woolpit
to want a building in elmswell were such
a site to be motivated
i think again a lot of it comes down to
that that word timing at the moment we
know that elm as well is going to be
over capacity this september
so as a as a place planning authority we
have a duty to provide places to to
pupils um when that when that school or
that area is oversubscribed and so we
will need places at ellsworth primary
school to meet the demands coming
through from september of this year
if a site were given to us in elmswell
to build a new school on tomorrow
for argument's sake it's probably going
to take best part of two to two and a
half years to develop a new school
we have to go through quite detailed
design and planning as you can imagine
and probably around a year to 15 months
at least of of new build time as well in
the meantime we're going to have a
school in elmswell which is going to be
oversubscribed by close to 100 pupils at
that point
and
you know we have an option to expand the
existing primary school so as a school
place planning authority
that has to be what the option that we
look at and that's why we're here today
to
to
ask for approval of the funding to be
able to do that
just
finally then um
if if the uh
if the extension to the existing outsole
school gives you breathing space through
to 2025
within
that space of time
you could develop the idea of another
school
within elmswell in preference to one in
woolpit where they were it were the site
to be made available to you
because if it takes two it takes two and
a half years yeah maybe and
i don't know what the build will take
after that
but it sounds to me as though by the
time elsewhere is full
um
if if you were in the position to start
now which is
again hypothetical um you could just
about have a new school ready at
elmswell just as readily as you could at
warp it is that
a reasonable
conclusion for me to reach
i think it's certainly one we would we
would
obviously consider we want to consider
all options when we've spoken to and
we've met with the parish council we've
met with local councillors local ward
members as well and and and
and put our case across in terms of why
we're while we're expanding elswell and
we've always said through it that
throughout that process we are willing
to consider
all options available to us i think it's
right and proper that we do that
um
my issue is as i said with with regards
to elmswell is the the current demand
coming through that we need to meet from
september 22. if a new school site was
then um
available to us
once that was agreed and those people
with that demand was met we'd have to
look at the
we'd have to look at that quite quite
closely because again we'd have to make
sure that any new school in elm as well
was sustainable as well because you'd
have a school of 420 places you could
have a school of
you know less than 200 places possibly
given all of the other growth coming
forward so we'd have to consider that
quite carefully and see how it how we
impacted on both but
as i say you know we do look at all
options as best we can but we have to
have
site of some certainty around the school
side before we really can get into that
detail and that sort of that sort of
discussion
and funding and all the other things
that come with that as well so we can we
can try and crystal ballgames as much as
possible to a certain extent but we do
need some degree of certainty around
land availability before we can really
do that
so given that we we this authority does
not control the the the provision of
of of education within within the
district
the county does
um
i'm concerned simply to establish
whether or not our granting um uh
approval for the expenditure of this
sale funding which seems to be necessary
in the short term anyway in order to
secure places at elmswell
our granting that does not necessarily
prejudice future development of schools
within elsewhere
it certainly doesn't prejudice it
but i can't sit here and say that it
would it would be a new school in
ellsworth should that happen we'd have
to look at everything in in the round
and look at what's best for the the
families and the communities of both
villages
could i add a point of information that
i'm not sure cabinet members are aware
of given the conversation that's been
happening
but um one of the new school sites is in
fact one of the potential new school
sites is actually owned by mid-suffolk
district council and so it could be made
available tomorrow
i've got a plan if anybody's interested
in where it is and what size
it is
6.25 acres i'm sorry that's more than
two hectares i haven't got it quite in
hectares
i'm sorry we can't we can't consider
that at this stage
councillor fleming did you did you have
a question
yes i did thank you um
thank you my my question again is is to
you peter um
you know this is obviously um
i would hope
not new ground that you've been
speaking
about these issues with the school
governors
and
the administration of the school
and um
what i would like you to tell us is what
is
their view i mean in theory i've seen in
in our papers that the
proposal for expansion is supported by
the administration and the governors can
you just elaborate a bit on that and
based on the consultation that's
happened
um
recently what is the overall view of
parents
i'll actually ask joe to to expand on
that question if i may because joe's
been involved with the consultation
process and with the school all
throughout the design and planning of
the new school expansion so
yeah so the head teacher and the
governing body are supportive of our
proposals
um in terms of
what what the project will provide at
the moment the school playing field is
incredibly waterlogged
so we're doing some work to improve the
drainage but also by providing the
mugger it means that the playing field
which they currently can't use for two
terms will be usable all year round
um i think that a question was raised
about changing rooms as well because of
the internal remodeling that we're doing
we'll take the changing rooms out of
effect actually the school don't use
those changing rooms and haven't done
for many years children get changed at
home and come to school in their pe kits
now so
in terms of what accommodation we are
providing the school are very happy and
supportive of that um and we've worked
with them to develop the proposals
throughout and so they're supportive yes
okay um
okay so i understand
clearly there is support in the school
administration governors for the
expansion and because this is obviously
very important um and it's very
important i i think that the
school administration
feels they're supported and that this is
a successful school and that investment
is available
to it to enable it to um
to thrive
and
i'm somewhat heartened to hear from the
conversation with councillor byrne
that
if we approve the
civil money for expansion
today that it does not necessarily
preclude
in the future
a new school being built in elsewhere if
the circumstances should indicate that
that
were to be desirable and possible
because i think that was a question that
counselor mellon put to you
just over a year ago
and
in fact i think that email is in our
papers but the response to it wasn't
and i was going to ask you that question
as well because it's a really key
question
i mean my view is that
very strong arguments have been made
about
the
desirability of building a new school
and the desirability of providing enough
space for children outdoors
which is increasingly recognized as
being you know vital to
their health and well-being
however i feel there's a real immediacy
here in in providing the space for local
children which we can do by approving
this money um and the school will be up
and running in time to meet that need
and um
you know i i feel it's a very balanced
and um
difficult decision to make but but my
view is that um you know i i will be
voting for
the um
sill
funding for the expansion and um you
know i think it's really important that
the district council and the county
council work really closely together you
know seeing that so much development's
happening in this area that we get you
know the education in schools part um
right as best we possibly can thank you
is this a question
i think
my question has been answered
in terms of the
support from the administration and
governors thank you thank you council
richardson
thank you chair that was actually my
question as well about whether it's um
the school is supportive of this option
so i think that's answered my question
thank you
hey any more question from cabinet
members okay any
questions from any other members present
counselor melon
yeah thank you chair um
i just wanted to unpick a little bit the
figures for
uh
next autumn september 20
2022.
i understand this is
horrendously complex
um but it seems to me that um you
haven't made a full case for the fact
that there will be too many pupils for
next september across elmsworld and
woolpit because there's so much spare
capacity at woolpit
is that correct
currently there is spare capacity at
wall pip um we won't be looking to to
add places into wall pit for certainly
next september
or the year after i would suspect and
and again you know that's that's
something we will be monitoring over
time um but for real as well itself our
forecast is showing that school will be
over capacity and as we have the option
to expand that school now
as a place planning authority we believe
our strategy to expand the school is
what's needed and what's best for that
community at this particular time um as
i've said already it doesn't preclude us
from from considering other options
we've been very grateful for the support
we've had from planning colleagues uh in
the in the district council around our
strategy going forward for for wallpaper
and elsewhere it's a tricky one we've
all talked about for some time
and we're really keen for those
discussions to continue we we don't want
to
walk away expanding elves well if that's
what happens uh and and and leave it
there we want to consider all options
that are then available to us and what's
best for the community and listening to
to all of the concerns that have rightly
been raised
but you know in answer to your question
at the moment we have a shortage of
places in elswell we have the
opportunity to meet
that demand by expanding the school for
september of 2022
and that's what our strategy and our ask
for approval is based upon
so i don't think you've quite grasped my
question which is about um
the combined capacity across the two
communities
will you still be if you add the two
together over capacity next
september according to the figures i
have i don't think you will be
no that's right across both villages we
wouldn't have um the need to
have places in walpole as well if you're
with me
i'm going to bring in tom barker
yes thank you i just wonder on this
point which um goes i suppose to the
issue where the the long-term strategy
is to consider the two villages
and the combination of schools between
the two villages and the longer term
solution of a new school new primary
school in walpier
that may potentially serve some um
children who live in elmswell
is um predicated upon the provision of
the new walking and cycling link
so that the the kind of the cohesiveness
of the strategy i suppose
is to
is to encourage the walking and cycle
into school where possible and the new
school in woolpit
would be timed at a point when that
pedestrian link is in place
whereas the existing school in walpier
i think is
more distant from elmsworld because it's
further to the south of the village and
would would therefore be
one further but if you were looking to
take children from elmswell into woolpit
as of september 22 that walking and
cycle link wouldn't be available to to
provide better connectivity between the
two
villages so i i'm not sure that's
necessarily a determinative factor but i
suppose i just wanted to kind of play
that out in terms of the the strategy is
to see
three schools serving the two villages
but it is also to see better
walking and cycling links between the
two villages
and um in advance of those better
walk-in and cycling links between the
two villages if you're kind of i suppose
just i'm perhaps taking um the thinking
of councillor mellon that well if that's
a good solution for the long term why
isn't that a good solution for the
immediate term of september and i think
that pedestrian and cycle
link the absence of that in september 22
would i suppose weigh against a
preference for using the long-term
solution in a more immediate term if
that's i just wanted to kind of just
just put that in in case it's helpful in
terms of
counsellors thinking
counselor
thank you chair and i very much
appreciate that point um
as as a question again to to pete um
it seems to me from what he said that
the
expansion of the existing school
somewhat undermines the case for a new
school in elmswell because the numbers
then don't add up
so it seems to me that this proposal
potentially prejudices
a three school solution of two schools
in ellsworth and one in walpit
would that be correct
i mean i would say no not necessarily um
as i've said we
we are looking at three schools as tom's
rightly pointed out across the two
villages i think three schools in in the
village to serve the development that we
know about now that's been
sent through to us to comment on and
develop divide strategies for
three the three three school option um
is is the one that we are we are
certainly looking at now as i said it
it is about the the place planning as i
say we we don't quite know where wall
pit primary school itself is going to be
in two or three years time
it might be that we see additional
pupils attending the school that
we aren't currently predicting because
as i say those forecasts can be quite
quite cyclical and can change quite
rapidly so it's something we'd have to
monitor over time
at the moment our view is expanding as i
said before you know elsewhere expansion
is is what's needed to meet the
immediate demand um
we have the option to do that we have a
sound option based on on the information
the design and the
the buying of the school and the
governance of the school as well to do
that um
but as i've said before we can't
preclude anything from from being
considered a new school in ellsworth may
be possible but we'd have to ensure that
there was that critical mass of pupils
i've talked about before because we
wouldn't want to have a small school
that could struggle to to be sustainable
in the current um current climate so
we'd have to look at
everything at that particular point but
at the moment we we can only really base
our strategy on what's available to us
and that's what we've tried to do from
the outset around land availability and
the pupil numbers and data that is that
is there
councillor geek
thank you chair could i just ask a quick
question of mr mumford um about uh the
um capacity of elmswealth school and the
projected forecasts i understood that
the june 2021 forecast was that um
there would be 277 total
uh children at elmswell school at the
end of 2024 to 25.
277 is less than 315 and we're going to
be seven spaces a year for up until
2025. that was the june forecast of this
year
do i have those numbers wrong
forecasts that i have and we update our
forecasts in the summer of every year
um that's to take into account all of
the new nhs uh
gp registrations data current trends and
what have you we update our forecasts in
the summer every year it's also based
upon the completion of the school
admissions round that we then have
certainty on how many pupils are going
to be at that school the following
september
so the forecasts
that have previously been shared will
have been the probably the the year
prior to that the forecast i've got here
that's sitting in front of me now shows
that for september was it sorry 24 25
was that the year yes
in july of this year
um i made a note that the june forecast
of this year was 277 total
uh
children at the school and had 315
capacity school and that there would be
seven places available
uh a year
and that you didn't expect that to
change
um
until 2025 before 2025. forecast to stay
the same until at least 2025. current
intake of 38 per year so a spare
capacity of seven and that that's
forecast to stay the same until at least
2025.
uh the the pan the annual intake at the
moment is 45 so as the current intake is
38 per year that's where that spare
capacity of seven comes from okay yeah
i'm with you now apologies yeah i think
i know what figures you're talking about
so that's the catchment
population um looking at the catchment
population at the school area and how
many actual arrivals we would expect in
in every september
we've now as i say with with the
forecast for this year we've added in
those pupils that have arrived from from
housing that's already being developed
as well so actually we're forecasting
the intake to be
in
2122 for instance we're forecasting a
reception intake of 55 pupils
oh so that's changed a great deal
since the so which forecast that's not
the june 2021
that would have been the the previous
year's forecast since then obviously
we've had pupils arriving from from new
um from new housing in the in the
village
and some of those trends are changing as
well it is a popular school you know
okay so when you said you weren't
expecting when you said a few months ago
you weren't expecting anything to change
until at least 20-25 you've been
surprised by this have you
i'm not entirely sure i meant it in that
context if i'm completely honest i'm not
entirely sure i i again apologies i know
this was a meeting we had some some
months ago
but the the issue of the over
subscription that elmswell has always
been there yes
sorry to interrupt is that the current
uh
the the higher year groups are larger
and so the current people's enroll are
292 but because those those high year
groups are larger you're expecting the
role to drop a bit
um as as you go down and now it seems to
be that you're expecting it to go up a
bit so i can quite see that these things
do change faster i'm just surprised
they've changed this fast no no i mean
and if they have changed this fast may
they not be again
changeable i mean i know that you can
only forecast what you can forecast i
think yeah i mean it's evidence the
point i've made all the way through that
the school place planning is is an
ever-changing um ever-changing beast and
we do try and
make sure that we we
calculate in all possibilities within
reason but it's really really difficult
we have seen a slight increase at elm as
well in terms of their their
applications and their reception
arrivals over the next few years we're
predicting predicting it to be anywhere
between 47 and 60 based on what i've
seen here over those next five years so
as i said the the school is going to be
in 24 25 for instance we're expecting
the school to be at capacity
you know they will reach their last year
before we then need to consider what the
other options are in terms of the new
school in warpie or something else in
ellsworth you know whatever we are
available to us and to consider at that
point in time but but certainly we have
seen
as i say some of those areas where we
have seen people
forecasts drop from from the primary age
population we're starting to see some
some trends of that that
beginning to reverse slightly so yes we
are expecting larger year groups than we
probably previously had in our forecasts
thank you thank you
so i'm now going to move this on to
debate
so cabinet members is there anybody
who'd like to
start the conversation council
richardson
thank you uh chair a couple of points
that i i want to make um so i think
first
obviously important i think just reflect
on this that we've received the advice
from the legal education authority um
with the support
of the school itself in elmswell
and they've presented
their recommendations to us based on
their available options
so i appreciate what's in this paper is
not necessarily a perfect solution um
but it is a solution nonetheless
um again i've considered this quite
carefully and i've heard some of the
questions that have been asked
and some of the responses received but i
think given the time scales involved we
will need the extra capacity by
september next year and with the absence
of the local
walking and cycling links that tom
barker mentioned
i do think combined with the uncertainty
that remains around the other
alternatives and what land could
potentially be available
i think this is and given that we are
it's incumbent upon ourselves to make a
decision one with the other um i think
i'll be supporting the recommendations
in this report um as for the reason set
out as i think many others have alluded
to already i know councillor fleming has
as well
um
just turning to uh something that
council byrd mentioned in his
introduction which i think is worth
clarifying it is in the detail of
appendix b the technical assessment but
just in terms of the thirst and bid i
did just want to emphasize that as as is
stated in in that appendix that there is
the
community user agreement that is was
previously attached to phases one and
two which is approved by cabin earlier
in the year however my understanding is
that the fulfillment
of that agreement has delayed the
progression of this bid
and so
while community access isn't directly
relevant to phases one and two
the exp the expediting of this process
is the reason for the removal of this
agreement as for this part of uh for
this stage of of the bids progression
but it is worth of course emphasizing
that it will remain a condition and a
requirement for phase three uh which
will be the delivery of the weather all
weather pitch which is uh obviously the
bit that the community will be wanting
to access so i think it's just important
emphasizing that um as part of the
debate that it will be included um in
the bid but just rather at a slightly
later stage um but on the whole yes i
will be supporting the recommendations
in the report thank you chair
thank you councillor richardson
councillor fleming did you want to come
um
because thank you thank you very much
officers
as well for clearing up a lot of points
that um you know i've really been
thinking about um
i mean i think it's clear that the
possibility of a
of a new school in elm swell is
obviously highly desirable but
unfortunately impractical to make the
immediate needs
of of the school and the local area
and i understand that the area
allocated for the school isn't ideal but
it does seem
that this opportunity also
allows us to improve the
opportunities for physical activity by
providing more all-around outdoor
activity and i think that also is really
important
i put a lot of weight on the fact that
the proposal is supported by the
school administration and governors um
as
councillor richardson has said
and i also fear that as has been
suggested that if this decision is
deferred to a later cabinet meeting to
allow us to think about it some more
the delay in the program um would imply
that the extension would not be
completed by the deadline
of
september 22 when it's needed
i feel the consequence of failing to
support expanding the school would
mean that some local children would not
be able to attend the local school of
their choice
and it would also indicate an
unjustified lack of support for the
present school
and i believe schools do need support
they need to know we
are listening to them and unwilling to
invest in them and it would be a missed
opportunity with far-reaching
consequences therefore i am um i'm going
to support the proposal today
thank you
councillor
shall leave you to last councillor burn
allow you to sum up
council
thank you um i agree with um councillor
fleming that of course new schools need
our support but i feel very
uncomfortable supporting this with them
with the parish council the um the
district councillor and the county
councillor all speak against it i do
feel it's a little bit short-sighted so
i should be voting against this
thank you anybody councillor whitehead
thank you um
i mean to aid our counsellor
decision-making function we employ
professional advisors professional
experts and i guess two fundamental
issues arise
should we take their advice
and should we question their advice and
i think the answer the first is yes
and the answer to the second is a
definite
it's definitely yes and we've done this
i mean outside this chain we've spent
considerable time already looking at
this ellenswell issue
and appendix d in our papers
dated 18th of october is the outcome of
that and it's very detailed paper
and i think it's important that the
elsewhere residents hear this i mean
to cut to the chase
decisions like this
are always looking at forecasts we're
always having to crystal ball games when
it comes to
future planning developments and i
suspect we're going to be faced with
many more like this along the a14
corridor in the future
so
it's not an easy decision but we have to
make one
and after considerable
consideration and on balance
i am coming down on the side of our
professional advisors
thank you
i think
my
opinion is that our role today is not to
decide
should we have a new school here or
should we have a new school there
our role today
is to
look at the recommendations put forward
by our technical advisors
and determine whether or not we should
spend this money
in this way
so
on balance my view is
we accept
the recommendations from our technical
advisors the school board of governors
which presumably includes the children
and our technical advisors our planning
officers
and our county council
representatives here today so on balance
my view is
that i will be voting for this
council byrne i'm going to allow you to
sum up
um yes thank you um
i don't need to point out i don't think
that for us um 1.5 million pounds is a
serious sum of money
and um
we have to make sure that uh
any decisions we we make about spending
the sill that we
we collect
um
are carried out with um
due diligence how then in this
particular case does that diligence
extend to
uh
interrogating
is that the right word um
no probably not
but at least asking the the the county
to justify its strategy
uh yeah i think there's a case
for us to to
say that that is part of our diligence
um
and and i think that uh
the county has responded today uh
satisfactorily in that sense
um
it seems to me to boil down to uh
there is a need for ex
extending the present capacity of their
own as well and the present capacity at
elmswell
can be achieved er extending
the extension that helds well can be
achieved
there's also
strategically
um a long-term need identified by the um
by the county for another uh another
school
another primary school in that area
shall we say because schools
uh
don't just
gather their pupils from
within the parish boundary that the
catchment extends beyond that and you
can reasonably expect to get
pupils coming from
um neighboring villages
so in this particular case it's it's um
is there
if woolpit and
elmswell are inextricably linked to that
extent
it's a case of saying well is that new
school going to be woolpit or is it
going to be elmswell and at the moment
it's looking very much like woolpit
because
that's what the county council had to
work with at the time they were trying
to make that decision
so i could fully understand that
i i was a tiny bit surprised by
councillor mellon's
last question
because he seemed to think the count the
county had not
um
satisfactorily
explained
why
they felt that it it it did not
prejudice
their decision did not prejudice the uh
the possibility of a school in helsill
because
my first line of questioning which was
extensive was designed to establish that
very point
um
was it uh has it closed the door
completely on the possibility of a
school in eldswell
i mean the reason why i'm concerned
about that is that yes i i fully
sympathize with councillor hattingham's
um
position it's very very
what's the right episode really i'm
fortunate that this
proposal does not carry
the
support of
all
the local representatives
councillors
parish councillors
it carries it carries the support of the
school in the school governors which is
considerable but unfortunately it
doesn't carry the support of
of the
the other members if you like of the
governance in in in the area and
i find that
unfortunate i mean it would be nice to
think that we were all pulling the same
direction and it's difficult that
somebody or a group is pulling in the
opposite direction which is why i wanted
to establish
whether or not
the door had been completely closed on a
new school in ellsworth
so
given that there is a need and an
immediate need and given that this is a
means of of meeting it
i'd think i am inclined to support it
but would ask the
the council
please to bear in mind that there is
considerable
opposition to it in elmsville
um
councillor geek has told us that there
is a site available and it's available
now
um
so please um
it won't affect my my vote
but please all i would say is i would
ask you to to
look into the possibilities of
of uh
it seems to me that it doesn't
and i don't know anything about it so
it seems to me that it doesn't really
matter
whether the school is in thurston or
whether it's in elsewhere if it's
elsewhere
no doubt many people in thurston will be
disappointed
if it's in thurston sorry a whole pit a
big apartment
if it's in if it's in uh
wool pit then obviously there are people
in oldsville that are going to be
disappointed so you can't please
everybody all of the time
but please do look into that possibility
uh there seems to be sight available in
houndsville there seems to be a lot of
support in helmsville um so
however the bottom line for me is that i
i feel we should be supporting this
motion and i feel too um that uh
there's no problem with supporting the
ounce of the uh thurston recommendation
um because the
uh
the community use of of that facility
will still be
will still be achieved i believe thank
you
thank you councillor and just for
clarity the the site mentioned by
councillor geek it should form no part
in our deliberations today it's not
relevant
uh i'm going to take the recommendations
the voting separately
to give everybody the greatest possible
choice in how they vote
so
item 3.1 i'm going to split into two
votes
one for the elmsworld primary school
increase from 315 to 420 places
and separately i'm going to take the
thurston additional land and school
community facilities
and then
recommendation 3.2 i'm going to take
separately as well
so i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
the recommendations on page 12
3.1
i'm going to split 3.1 into two separate
votes
so elms will we will vote separately
from the thurston
and then that also the knock-on effect
of that is also that 3.2 will be taken
separately as well
thank you chair
the first vote is now in progress and
that is the vote for elswell
so chair that is seven votes four and uh
one vote against
thank you
and the next round
the next vote which is for thurston is
now in progress
and chair that is eight votes for that's
uh
thank you and item 3.2
sorry and that vote is now in progress
as well
cancer fleming have you
voted
yes please
may i take your vote verbally
that is eight votes for chair
thank you very much
thank you councillors
as we move on to item nine
um mca 21-26
is the infrastructure funding statement
from mid-suffolk
um april
to march 2021
cabinet has agreed that this
infrastructure funding statement and
future count statements will be
circulated to all members and published
on the council's website in june of
course therefore this item will not be
presented to cabinet today
i just wonder whether council burn did
you want to add anything to that
did you want to add anything
for item 9.
i think
notes say that we're not going to
discuss this
sorry tom
if it helps um
certainly this item was discussed at
briefing and there was an agreement that
it didn't need to come to cabinet it
would simply be published it is simply a
statement of fact and the recommendation
was solely for noting
given that it did make its way onto the
agenda
i was uncertain whether it would be
presented and whether councillors would
take a vote to
note the item
and therefore did talk through with
councillor byrne um what an introduction
to the item might look like
um so
ultimately it's it's a statement of fact
and the recommendation is solely for
noting within the report that is on your
agenda so
i think from an officer perspective it
matters not
really um whether you
hear the item
or whether you remove it from the agenda
certainly it went through briefing and
there were no
questions or concerns about items that
were on it
so
for reasons of transparency i suppose
given that it was on the agenda you
could simply
note the item and counselor burn could
introduce it or given that it's a
statement of fact without a decision to
make
you could simply
do as you suggested
when you introduced it
counselor burn how would you like to
proceed
will that proceed proceed proceed well
okay because i think i should um
it it is an agenda item i think
viewers of this
this particular meeting
uh
transparency was the word that uh
um
and i think that's it's right that for
transparency reasons we should
we should just i should just introduce
this
uh and anna and i'll explain a little
bit about it um
albeit this is a much shorter item than
the previous one
um
there has been a huge amount of work uh
carried out by officers on this one as
well
it takes an awful lot of putting
together
when government amended the sale
regulations it sent in september 2019
they introduced a requirement and it was
a requirement to publish an
infrastructure funding statement now
this is essentially a monitoring report
on what sale money has been collected
and spent what section 106 money and
other obligations have been achieved and
what money has been sent to parishes
what projects have been supported and
what projects are expected to come
forward
this report is simply asking that
cabinet note the contents of the
statement
and that it will be sent to government
and published on the council's website
there is a lot of information within it
but it's essentially as tom said a
statement of fact for the period april
2020 to march 21
but because it is simply for noting
and it is something that we have to
we have to produce in any event
and it is a statement of fact
given all these i propose that this is
the last time we bring this report to a
formal cabinet meeting
it's important and interesting
information but there's no decision for
us to take
we have to publish the information so it
has to come before you for noting but in
future
we will send it to all councillors for
information publish it on our website
and provide briefings if they would be
helpful but we will not be bringing the
cabinet on after this particular
occasion
on that basis i move the recommendation
which is simply to note
note the
the paper and
i'll just ask for a second for that
please
thank you council burn do i have a
secondary
council gold
thank you so i'm going to ask a
government officer to conduct the vote
for 3.1 and 3.2 together
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
chair that is eight votes full
thank you very much um i'm gonna call a
break now we've been going for almost an
hour and a half so
um
if we break now and reconvene at 12
o'clock we'll start again at 12 o'clock
thank you councillors
we're now moving on to
mca
mca 21-27
and this is the funding to support our
strategic
priorities
i'm delighted to present these proposals
for just over five million pounds worth
of investment
to support our district
to thrive over the next few years and to
recover well from the impacts of the
covid pandemic
while these proposals focus primarily on
our strategic priorities relating to the
economy communities well-being and
housing
they also include further investment in
projects that support our climate change
ambitions
this is of course in addition to the 1
million investment already set aside in
reserves
for climate change and biodiversity
these proposals were developed following
cross-party input at all member
workshops and the key themes arriving
arising from those workshops are set out
at pages 204 and 205 of your papers
today
i would like to book on record my thanks
to members of all parties for your
contributions
this package of proposals supports
business growth and innovation
enables new and higher level skills
increases apprenticeships and the role
out of faster broadband
it tackles homelessness and provides
support to homeless people beyond just a
roof over their head
these proposals also support more
sustainable housing reduce fuel deposit
reduce fuel poverty
encourage more community land trusts
and adds additional capacity to develop
and deliver neighbourhood plans
they embrace the well-being of our
communities
addressing isolation loneliness
inactivity dementia
victims of domestic abuse and
sustainable travel to mention but a few
young people are also at the centre of
these proposals with our biggest single
investment being in a new youth social
prescribing scheme
there are also more grants for community
groups to recover from covid and support
to retain and develop
those fantastic volunteers so vital to
our communities during the pandemic and
beyond
however we also recognize that if we're
going to continue to be truly ambitious
we need to set aside investment to
assess feasibility and build business
cases
for those big ideas
such as retrofit for all tenures or
truly affordable housing solutions
we want to press on to look at our
options in these areas
and so to conclude i'm very proud of the
proposals i've i'm setting out today and
i believe that they will make a real
difference to our local communities
however the cabinet recognises that as
we continue to live with and recover
from kovic 19 we can also expect to see
emerging new needs and opportunities
we therefore want to keep all our
strategies and delivery plans dynamic
so that we can respond to our
fast-changing environment and continue
to work together to build great
communities with bright and healthy
futures that everybody is proud to call
home
i'm going to move the recommendations at
paragraph three of this report and call
for a seconder
thank you and
i'm now going to ask or invite each of
the four portfolio holders
to say a few words
about their portfolio in this matter
and as councillor brewster is not is
unable to be with us today
i will be saying a few words on his
behalf
i'm going to start with councillor
flatman
thank you chair
as the chair has just
pointed out
our vision for communities is great
communities with bright and healthy
futures that everyone is proud to call
home
our mission is to provide strong proud
inspirational leadership striving for
excellence and together building great
communities
everyone for everyone to live work visit
and invest in
the community's strategic
strategy
is communities that thrive now in the
future built on balanced and targeted
range of services
and support equally accessible to all
our residents and their future
generations
delivery in recent years
mid-suffolk district council has
developed and adopted a community
strategy a well-being strategy adopted
on the 23rd of september and a leisure
sport and physical activity strategy
the next steps each strategy will have a
delivery plan that complements each
other designed to ensure
that the agreed priorities outcomes are
realized the funding will help in
supporting and realizing our aspirations
as reflected in many of the initiative
initiatives and proposals as set out in
the report
additional grants to increase increased
community resilience and recovery from
the impact of covert 19
neighbor neighborhood planning emerging
needs grants
two hundred and fifty thousand
community aspirations have been
identified from neighborhood plans many
of which align with our objectives
agreed in the community strategy
the lspa strategy and the well-being
strategy
use of disgrace
discretionary grants to fund these
initiatives
that will create community space or
spaces support health and well-being
initiatives and services new or improved
community hall provision meeting spaces
community cafes community gardens sports
and outdoor gym equipment and recreation
facilities and other community
infrastructure identified will
significantly control contribute to the
delivery of all these strategies and
delivery plans
the review of neighborhood plans also
pulled out a community desire pulled out
of the community desire to be involved
in
talking forward
taking forward ideas such as those
identified above supported by the
councils communities would be enabled to
contribute and steer the delivery and
sustainability of community improvements
and infrastructure
further contributing to the council's
ambitions to encourage a skilled
knowledgeable and enabled volunteer base
actively respond to issues outlined in
neighborhood plans would also go some
way to fostering strong and effective
community relationships
and give confidence and there is council
support to help delivery of community
neighborhood plans
the covert recovery grants for community
groups a hundred thousand the covert 19
pandemic has had significant impact on
us all as individuals families and
communities these impacts are diverse
and varied
on the one hand effects have been felt
by community facilities arts and
cultural organizations welfare support
charities and youth providers and have
lost income and some charities have
folded eg age uk suffolk
on the other hand the strength of our
community shone through the in a
multitude of ways in which people have
supported each other
this is something that we
we want to harness and stimulate
stimulate further in line with our
aspirations of communities of the
community strategy
the aim of the fund is to enable vcses
organizations to resume their previous
activities
to support them to transition to new
ways of working and to help rebuild
participation and income streams
support will be directed to those vcse
or
sd organizations that support the
outcomes of the wellbeing strategy
focusing on mental health and wellbeing
social isolation and connecting
communities
okay for those um volunt vcses voluntary
community and social sector just so you
know what i'm talking about
uh further grants to support community
facilities improve accessibility and
green initiatives two hundred thousand
to boost capital funding available to
improvements to community facilities
demand for major capital community
grants funding stream is increasing year
on year much of the 21 22 capital budget
has already been allocated to projects
across the district and if we are to
respond and support groups to help
deliver the ambitions of the emerging
well-being strategy and the lspa
strategy
then we need to ensure we can support
improvements required to physical
community assets facilities for
increased community use nearer to where
people live eg equipment or improvements
to the facilities to encourage sports
and leisure nearer to where people live
the criteria for this fund will also
encourage the development of green
initiatives to support the council's
environmental
environmental objectives such as the use
of solar panels air source heat pumps
etcetera
for eg village halls
the community volunteer mentoring
eight eighty thousand
appointed volunteer coordinator to
support the development of a skilled and
enabled volunteer base the role will
work with all existing known volunteers
and community groups review where there
may be quiet patches across the district
with regards to volunteering and work to
establish new groups
we all also we also witnessed throughout
the pandemic the strength of our
communities in the multitude of ways in
which they were they supported each
other this is something that we we want
to harness and develop in line with our
community strategy
work with volunteers and organizations
such as community action suffolk and
established vcse
organization to understand what tools
training and incentives may need to be
developed to encourage a diverse range
of volunteers and ensure their
sustainability the role would also work
with our other teams to create projects
in support of the wellbeing strategy
building into our proposals exciting
opportunities to the volunteer
the role would also offer support to
increase the skills and capability of
our local sports clubs upskilling of the
leisure operator volunteer base to
support delivery of targeted and
specialized health and wellbeing
interventions and more inclusive service
thank you chairman members
thank you councillor flatman for the
communities
um
for the economy uh theme one is about
improving the aspirations of young
people
and this theme is around how we provide
support and inspiration to young people
to encourage them
to have aspirations for their future and
take their active place in the workforce
as they grow up
theme two is around increasing
innovation growing business and raising
skills and high value jobs and
supporting businesses to grow innovate
and reach new audiences
already we have some exceptional
businesses in mid-suffolk but to ensure
that our economy grows in the future we
will need more innovative and
aspirational businesses opening in the
district
and of course gateway 14
will support that
this theme will support much of the need
for additional infrastructure
for example ultra fast broadband
business case for an innovation and
skills center at gateway 14
and extending and diversifying the
innovation hub model in stone market and
i as well
it also provides the opportunity to
target apprenticeships for sectors with
skills gaps
as well as the partnership with essex
university
to deliver the knowledge transfer
program for smes
theme three is around sustainable travel
i think this one speaks for itself but
it's to ensure that we have the finance
to support sustainable travel which is
currently being worked on
theme four is around the town centre
visioning work
and again
um
this this does speak for itself but
funding for the town centre vision work
for stone market eye and need a market
will help to ensure customer footfall
an attraction to those towns to help
make the businesses in them more
successful
thing five is around support for key
covert recovery projects and being bid
rev
ready
um
so that's it for economy i'm now going
to invite councillor hadim to speak on
behalf of housing
thank you
i have to say that i'm really excited
about the ideas that we discussed across
party earlier this year in june and now
being agreed and can go forward
shelter has always been a basic need
since time began and it's also the
foundation of what we as a kid district
council provide
our vision our strategic strategic
priority for housing in our corporate
plan is
residents are settled with safe
healthy lives in affordable and high
quality homes
so feedback into this included building
more of our own homes through the
mid-suffolk growth group including
highly sustainable housing projects
exploring how we might achieve truly
affordable housing solutions across all
tenures and providing homeless support
that goes beyond just a roof and include
support for mental health skills and
jobs and helps with drug and alcohol
dependency
the proposal we are putting forward
today
includes increasing housing by
supporting the delivery of new homes by
adding additional staffing capacity to
find sites for the growth company to
build new homes and explore the
feasibility of delivering service plots
with outline planning permission for
self build or custom build on
council-owned land and look at the
benefits of delivering housing through
modern methods of construction which
also positively affect management and
maintenance
increasing available housing by bringing
back more empty homes into use by
enabling owners to apply for money on
top of the current grant to do the
required work to bring the property back
into use
an additional additional officer to work
proactively on these cases and then
promote any owners wishing to rent to
utilize central suffolk lettings
the development of a community trust
loan fund to encourage an
increase
an increase in community-led affordable
housing for local people by helping with
the deposits needed to enable them to
attain mortgages allowing more residents
in need to access homes from their local
communities
an increase increase environmental
standards in our own and others houses
an absolute win-win situation where
residents will live in more energy
efficient homes and it will also support
our targets in the carbon reduction
management plan
in the cup in the private rental sector
targeting landlords with the lowest epc
ratings and creating a loan scheme to
fund the works to improve them and by
commissioning a feasibility study for
building new housing of an environmental
exemplar standard this would demonstrate
the council's ambition to carbon zero
and lead by example in response
in response to this detect
sustainability agenda learning from this
could be shared with developers
regarding feature design and viability
of new housing standards
expanding
central suffolk lettings by increasing
cash incentives to landlords and mental
top-ups so more residents can access the
private rental sector and with a
dedicated tenancy support officer we
feel that homelessness will be prevented
in more cases and there will be less
dependency on temporary accommodation
and social houses this will not only
have a financial benefit but will have
significant benefits for residents
enabling them to remain living close to
schooling employment and supply networks
improving temporary accommodation by
developing a required standard and
expecting all current accommodation to
ensure all units meet it and can
continue to maintain it which will in
turn will be reduce void times and time
spent in b b's enabling residents to
live safely and comfortably during their
time in temporary accommodation
creating an employment advisor for the
homeless to give them dedicated support
to training and employment opportunities
including apprenticeships which will
reduce the likelihood of residents
returning to the streets and expanding
the adult social cri
prescribing model to increase their
well-being health
all in all i haven't mentioned
everything so i didn't want to hold too
much time but i feel that this proposal
will improve the lives of many of our
residents and their families and goes a
long way to living up to the council's
vision and i'm happy and grateful to
have been a part of it thank you
thank you councillor
and now councillor richardson for
well-being
thank you very much chair um i'm
absolutely delighted that these
proposals have come to fruition and
they're being included um especially the
fact that we've exceeded the amounts
that we agreed in the budget in february
what this allows us to do in terms of
well-being is provide new dedicated
funding to support the delivery of our
new and dedicated wellbeing strategy
again much similar to the other my other
cabinet colleagues this is split into
key themes and those are there are three
main ones here for well-being the first
is that we are targeting support to
specific adult groups such as those who
have experienced loneliness and
isolation and those suffering from
dementia as well as extending the
support that we can offer to some of our
more rural communities
the second is is it with a particular
emphasis on on young people and i think
including those those sort of two broad
groups is especially important because
they have been or they have been
and continue to be to some extent
affected very deeply by the impact of
the pandemic and supporting them to
recover from that is absolutely
essential and by adopting that approach
we can also and targeting our funding to
those specific areas we can maximize the
impact that we have on our residents and
those who are most in need as uh council
morley quite rightly said in the
introduction the single biggest
investment of 360 000 is in a new social
prescribing scheme for young people
which will be rolled out across our
district and which we hope will impact
uh positively the lives of many people
that we represent
the other aspect which i know came out
quite strongly in the debates when we
had the well-being strategy come forward
to the council in september is the
desire to see
the concept of well-being embedded
within our planning system i think there
was a kind of universal recognition
that's absolutely something we want to
do
and i know and personally it's something
i'm very keen on and i know the planning
offices are supportive of that as well
and so i think what this funding will do
is enable that to actually become a
reality
because i think ultimately when i when i
reflect on on what it is we're trying to
achieve here we are effectively and i've
mentioned this previously we are
extending our core statutory obligations
we're providing additional support
additional services to our residents
which we can only do because of the uh
advantageous financial position that we
find ourselves in as a council and so i
really think that this uh this new
funding proposal which i will absolutely
be supporting if i hadn't mentioned that
already um i think is actually a really
welcome step to helping uh achieve and
realize the ambitious objectives that we
set in our new well-being strategy and
really actually empowers us to work
in collaboration with the ccgs with
primary care with other local voluntary
groups um and and other partners as well
and i think that's really important
because we must recognize that within
this space we must work with others this
is a really welcome step forward to
enable us to achieve some of those
aspirations but we must do that in
collaboration with others and i think
this gives us a really
serious and meaningful offer to those
partners to say that we are here we have
stepped up to the plate and we will
absolutely be doing everything we can to
support our residents
all of which will then help deliver the
core vision that we have for well-being
which is for our residents to have the
best possible conditions
for good well-being and for lives that
are healthy happy and rewarding and i
absolutely think this is a a big step
for us in helping to achieve that thank
you jen
thank you councillors
i'm now going to move into questions um
and i've got a full set of assistant
directors here to
help delve into the detail should you
wish
and
who wishes to ask a question
counselor
thank you chair i've got i've got
several questions
um
first can i welcome much of what what
has been said wasn't it a brilliant idea
who have ever had the idea that we
should spend some of this money instead
of keeping it in jam jar so
welcome i welcome this
um one of the questions is around staff
resources
um what steps have been taken to recruit
additional staff we've seen through
looking at the themes
a significant number of extra staff will
be required
um are we taking steps to recruit them
now
will they be permanent will they be
short-term contracts or are we going to
be relying on agency staff i hope it's
not
the latter
um
do you want to take the questions one or
two at a time or
i think we'll take them one at a time
okay
well that one stands alone some of the
others there's a theme through them okay
i'm going to
invite arthur to respond to that one
thank you chairman and thank you
councillor william for the question so
in terms of recruitment but clearly
cabinet hasn't approved this yet so
nothing has started in terms of
recruitment to those posts yet it's
subject to to that being approved today
and i suppose technically also subject
to call in as well so that would have to
have a standstill period before we could
begin doing so
you'll see across the document though a
number of references to different types
of staff so it's difficult to give you a
definitive answer it varies from
area to area as to whether those are
permanent staff whether those are
temporary arrangements and whether those
are fixed term posts
but i'm sure outside of the meeting we
can provide all councillors with a
rundown of exactly how that's made up
and if it in fact a breakdown of exactly
how those posts would be will be
provided
thank you um
there was a reference to delivery of new
homes it's on page 207
and staffing will be asked to find
sites to be developed
um
will will
all or some of these be for social
housing please
you know i'm sure some of them will be
yes you know i can't give you a ratio
but yeah
thank you
um
moving on to well-being
um
the youth
prescribing scheme i
welcome councillor richardson saying
that this will be available
district-wide um
i think i think i'm right in assuming
that you did say that it would be
district-wide so available in any part
of the district
i'm just wondering how this will be
achieved
because it seems to have been
very sort of localizing
two or three different parts of the
district at present so is it going to be
truly available district-wide how do we
make sure it is
and i've got a question about the school
holiday programs um welcome the 30 the
30 000 that that is
being put into that um
who will be able to benefit from this
and why are you saying it's half term
why not christmas and easter i would
have thought christmas would be
a time when it would be particularly
necessary thank you
council richardson
thank you chair yes if i can answer
those two questions um the first on
social youth social prescribing so
that's being delivered at the moment
through or will be delivered through the
integrated neighborhood teams so at the
moment where we've done pilots they have
been quite specific to a particular area
but with by engaging with the integrated
neighborhood teams we can expand that
across some of the more rural areas so
there's a there's a very rural int in
the very sort of west of the district um
but actually there is going to be a
draft a report specifically on youth
social prescribing um that will be
shared for discussion with key
stakeholders because that is one area
where we absolutely which i mentioned in
sort of my my contribution was that it's
not something that's solely within our
gift is something that we absolutely
have to work
in partnership with um and so work in
partnership with others to deliver that
so that's still being developed and i
would expect to see some more details on
the specifics within the delivery plan
and in terms of the
holiday holiday activity fund so there's
i think there are sort of two questions
there the first is around the
eligibility unless i'm unless any
officer can clarify i don't think that's
been confirmed as yet um but may again
come forward in the delivery plan if we
don't have that level of detail the
second point around which is kind of a
bit more simple around why we're not
doing it around the other main school
holidays is that that's already been
provided by department of education
funding but what it doesn't do is cover
half term so that's why we've got the 30
000 explicitly for the half-term period
because there's already funding in place
to cover the other periods um thank you
chair
did you have another question yeah yes
i've got one or two more um uh one is to
do with the support being given to
parishes or rather the parishes that
aren't producing neighborhood plans i
mean they're an excellent way for the
parishes that do produce them
to
set out how they want to develop
but i think a lot of a lot of the
communities work needs to be done not
just within separate parishes but across
groups of parishes
so if there are if there are small rural
parishes
which
have no intention of
producing a
well they have the resources to produce
a neighborhood plan how are we going to
make sure that the community facilities
are are being provided across groups of
materials of parishes we don't want
every parish to request a village hall
when there is
these are pooled resources they can have
a really one really good village hall or
one very good community hall um without
everybody having a small one
but how are we going to achieve this can
you stop that one
yes i mean a lot of um a lot of um small
villagers do get together now i mean i
know when we've been
developing our um our our neighborhood
planet stradbroke all the neighbourhood
and villagers were invited to come and
have a look and so they all joined in
and took bits away to work on and just
on the neighborhood plans before we go
into your other question this
neighborhood plan is not just for
neighborhood plans that are not being
produced yet it's for the refresher
neighborhood plans and revisiting your
neighborhood plans which i think needs
to be done every three to four years so
that that work will be
you know for those people as well
um and as you said with the we do um
have parish liaison meetings with the
council now and that's where we could
introduce um joined up thinking there
when we're having these meetings you
know the town and parish magazine um um
meetings we have regular
yeah yes uh yeah i mean yeah that's
that's helpful but
i'm i'm thinking about the parishes
where the residents are keen to
um to have facilities to have
activities and so on um
but
because the parish councils
are
more reluctant to get involved in
producing this sort of thing there's a
lot of parishes out there we've got
paris councils that don't do very much
but the residents want to do a lot more
and it's easy to say well they must get
themselves onto the parish council
that's you know that
that's not the answer to the problem the
what we what we need to do is make sure
that facilities are available so that
everyone can use them
and i think i think what you're going to
see is we're done with our our locality
officers they will be able to help with
this getting people together in that
locality having the conversation yeah
we're not going to build a new village
hall in a
in a hamlet with 90 residents i mean
that's madness but we will open up
conversations and hopefully you know
people can get together
thank you i'm going to bring nadeem in
on this one
um i i think council flatman's just
really stolen my thunder i was going to
say exactly that we are moving towards
locality-based working and it's really
important that on a locality base we
actually work with stakeholders and
including those parish councils which
may
not want to
develop neighborhood plans but in
relation to some of those key issues in
terms of those localities is how we work
with them in terms of tackling those
priorities in those local areas
thank you i've just got two more
questions sorry to take so long um these
are fairly straightforward the
sustainable travel um
plan that
that um one of the cabinet members
referred to and there's um
a 100k
in that sort of theme
is that intended for infrastructure or
what what sort of thing is that likely
to be spent on
if it's infrastructure it's not going to
go very far or is it to ensure that
infrastructure is provided but then the
county haven't set aside any money for
it either
so where where we where are we going
with supporting
sustainable travel i'm gonna i'm gonna
bring fiona in on on this one thank you
thanks and uh
so we already already also uh have a
sustainable travel officer he's been
working very closely as you know with
with councillors and suffolk county
council um we know the hundred thousand
isn't going to go too far if we start
building actual uh footways but it might
be used to lever in other funding pots
sometimes we have to put a small amount
of funding match funding down so that
that will be helpful in that instance
also um
catherine our sustainable travel officer
is moving uh increasingly into working
with businesses for example around
travel
incentives and a little bit of seed
funding in that instance is really
helpful at the moment we have the post
funded but we don't have any sort of
seed funding to support it so that's
what that hundred thousands for
thank you and my last question is um how
will members across the council
particularly local members local ward
members be involved in developing these
proposals
i'm going to bring in a strategic
director on this cathy
as you know that and at the monthly all
member briefings that um we are um we we
theme them each time and in accordance
with the um six strategic priorities so
there will be an opportunity at those to
both hear what we're doing but also um
to discuss them further
thank you
thank you council richardson
uh thank you chad i just wanted to come
back on a couple of uh councillor
willem's point the first around when he
was asking about the eligibility for
some of the holiday activities i did
actually have the eligibility
information to hand i was just looking
at the wrong page of my notes um so this
sort of the baseline assumption we're
making is it'll be it'll be um
the eligibility will be based on those
who receive free school meals but as
part of sort of the further work that
we're developing we may look to see
whether we can extend that
um and then just turning to actually the
question that he's
you've just asked um is that this work
for the from the well-being perspective
uh a lot of what's in here will be
feeding into the delivery plan and we've
i've got a cabinet members briefing on
wednesday i think of this week where on
the agenda is working out what the plan
will be to engage the opposition groups
as well um which of course i commit but
i think i made to yourself when we
discuss the well-being strategy so that
they'll be within the context of the
delivery plan
there will be the opportunity to engage
in what's in here as well
thank you councillor field
thank you the council richardson may
have to
answered something justin the the
i have to say before i ask you a
question is really i'd hope that
cross-party working would involve a bit
more than suddenly finding out a list of
things that you want to do
although they were obviously developed
after the workshops we had early on in
the on the year but
my real question i guess is that
looking at this we've got a reasonably
substantial sum of money you have five
million pounds is not trivial but it
seems to have been salami sliced up into
a lot of quite small suns
and i was really gonna question do you
do you really feel we can deliver
with these small subdivisions would it
be better to focus on fewer but larger
tasks and just give you an illustration
of what i'm talking about if i may
there's one theme increase standards
standards in their own
and others houses
and it includes
uh 150 k a hundred code which is a loan
now the the government scheme of this
nature has which had several billion
pounds in it has failed abysmally to
achieve very much
um
and one of the thoughts is that you know
perhaps improving energy efficiency in a
home is a
15k process so this covers perhaps 10
homes
i think there's quite a lot more than
that in mid-suffolk um quite a few tens
of thousands so it does seem to be it's
it's
a very small sum to to assign to quite
an important subject
similarly the 300 k on
high quality sustainable housing
we have had an exam class scheme before
i think it was in elsewhere which which
worked pretty well many quite a few
years back
clearly it would be good to design a new
one
but a fund to top up an additional cost
per property
for a small example scheme well again
one's never too sure builders will tell
you that the cost per property is
dramatic some of us may think it's down
about 3k
there's no indication here of what sort
of
number of properties or
whatever how big a scheme you're you're
thinking of would you mind summarizing
your questions because
the question the real question
is
is it right to divide this sum of money
into relatively small sums assigned to a
whole raft of different ideas
or would it actually yield us more if
you focused on fewer larger tasks
thank you and first of all i i feel i
must correct you before i bring in
counsellors or direct
assistant directors you said
this is a list of things that we want to
do
this is we being the council this is
what all members
signed up to or asked for
in
in our workshop so this is not a cabinet
sitting here magic magicking
things to do out of the air this is what
all members have said they want to see
councillor galt
thanks i'm
listening to with interest to cancer
fields
um
question uh and
started some thoughts running but i i'd
like to
repay his question with a question to
him if i may which is what are the
things that he would leave out
of the program
well i did enjoy spending quite a bit of
sunday reading your the documents
i i really would have difficulty in
answering that immediately but it would
be
essentially some of the smaller aspects
and it's always difficult to make
choices isn't it but if you have limited
sum of money if you spread it around in
in one pound at a time you get very
little if you bunch it up into bigger
items you you get
more yield
for instance you ran a a good event
worse did last week
and someone was really peddling the idea
of community systems for things like
solar panels or ground source heat or
whatever
you could put the council's money behind
a large scheme and achieve
quite a
a national splash if you like something
which would be
which would be visible to to
even across the country perhaps because
it was dramatic and successful we're
splitting it up into a few pounds for
each one of a whole variety of films i
feel is a
is surprising particularly in there
there was 50 grand to go and look at the
ducting of
in our cities
to determine whether we could
encourage more high speed fibre
i always have a feeling that bt my
ex-employer knows pretty well where all
those ducks are so just what are we
going to achieve with 50 grand in that
area thank you
councillor flatman
a small amount a p of money to a very
small organization trying to keep the
float um say 200 pounds
means a lot to a small group trying to
run an over 60s club
okay that will then enable them to go to
somebody else and ask for some grant
funding as well so
that's why all of our projects are
working with our partners because you
only need a little seed to grow a big
plan thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chair um i was actually going
to say something very similar to what
council flatman was going to say and if
i can just sort of draw on the examples
i've got within the wellbeing funding
we've got everything from the largest
single item within this paper which is
the youth social prescribing scheme
which i think is quite a big ambitious
scheme but we also do have those smaller
elements that can have a really
meaningful impact on people's lives so
the smallest for example is 25 000 to
support those living with dementia um
with sort of music sessions local music
musicians training events linked with
care homes and dementia groups and given
the sort of the complexities and all of
the nuances involved in that particular
disease and the impact of the pandemic i
think a small amount of funding can have
quite a big impact which i think is sort
of what i needed to in my contribution
earlier and i think we shouldn't
underestimate that exactly as council
flatman said that those smaller amounts
of money money can actually make a very
good big impact on some of the specific
targeted groups that might otherwise get
lost and i think if i can just draw on
another example
and this is just personal my own
experience as a local ward member that
some sort of the most
impact that i can have on local groups
and the most sort of positive feedback i
get is from the spending of my locality
funding that's where i can make a real
tangible impact to quite small community
groups with a relatively small sum of
money so i think it shouldn't i don't
think be a case of doing either raw we
have got those bigger ambitious projects
in here but we've also got those smaller
pieces of work which may not seem like
big sums of money to us but could have a
real impact on on some of our residents
and our communities particularly those
sort of more vulnerable and more
isolated thank you chair
thank you councillor hayden
thank you and um i just want to say that
like you say some of those smaller
slices of money are going into
feasibility studies to look at how we
can you know like modern methods of con
construction and stuff like that like
say it's not going to build very many
houses but if we look into how much
money can we save in the future for
doing this that's what it's doing going
into extra staffing to look at things
councilman
thank you chair um just a couple of
questions the first one's a general one
um obviously this is a large um
a large amount of money to spend um i
just wonder what the timing of this
expenditure is going to be is this money
you expected to have spent by the end of
this the term of this council
so the majority of this investment spend
we see taking place in this and the next
financial year
in order to support
our district and our
residents and businesses to recover from
the pandemic
however some projects like the social
prescribing
one
these are supported by two year
fixed term staff posts
and so those will go on for longer and
at the end of that period we will then
review
where and if the pump priming monies
that we've
put into these projects have been
sufficient
and where our long-term funding
more long-term funding is required
so
my intention is that
we want to see
the social return on all this investment
ideally within the next 18 months to two
years
thank you um the second question is um
and john field um
referred to this that we have had an
exemplar scheme for for low-cost housing
using modern methods of construction
at claylands in in elmswell which
um
was apparently featured on grand designs
and and uh
won an award from the royal institute of
british architects so are we confident
we learned the lessons from that
project um
before we we do another example of
scheme
uh pilots
thank you
councillor i said that was before my
time so i'm going to put that together
thank you chad
um
the the the money proposed for the
exemplar project is uh potentially a
housing revenue account
site and and thus
learning and developing through our new
build specification um
and um that's coming forward as part of
the hra business plan in the next few
months so i think we're always actively
looking at what else has gone before um
but we know that in this area there is a
lot of a lot of advance
at pace and thus it would be pertinent
to to look at new technologies as they
come forward um and if i could just take
the opportunity to come back to to to
council of fields point um for example
in the work in relation to to energy
efficiency in the private rented sector
that may seem a small amount of money
but it builds on existing monies that
are already there and are available
through through loans and grants which
means that we can do um even more
mid-south it has more than 500 privately
rented homes that currently have an epc
of f4g
and we've recently received additional
funding and now working with all suffolk
authorities
to bring forward a project which targets
those privately rented homes across
suffolk
to to increase and improve their energy
performance
and naturally if that's also empty homes
that's bringing empty homes back into
stock and and thus perhaps preventing
the need to build another home
thank you
any more questions
then are going to move into
to debate
i think we've
had quite a good debate already so far
actually
cancer gold
thanks very much uh
chair
i think to me this feels like a very low
key occasion for such a tremendous
program of actions and investments that
will have a real impact on the lives of
people within our district
this truly is an impressive array of
investments and actions
you must recognize that the money to
make these investments is a product of a
sustained period of good financial
management and planning
and the proposals make an intelligent
use of resources
and many of the projects will either
produce future financial benefits or
reduce future calls on public resources
and social prescribing
is a good example of that
we're also very effective as a council
using seed funding to attract
substantial external funding so while
taking councillor field's challenge
a small sum doesn't equate to a small
impact or benefit as a number of
colleagues have have pointed out
i think particularly strength of this as
you said in your opening remarks yeah
is that all councillors have had the
opportunity to contribute their ideas
and suggestions no one has a monopoly of
good ideas and this administration is
secure
and confident
so as to invite everyone to participate
it is the administration's task to draw
this into a deliverable program
and this is what we have
before us today
my caution
is uh that we don't add unnecessarily to
the council's cost base so taking
council welling's opening question about
staffing we should not be making
permanent appointments
to time limited
to time limited projects
let's keep something in the jam jars as
we make these substantial investments in
our district thank you very much chair
councillor whitehead
yeah thank you chair um
the spending commitments are being
recommended today
are being financed from reserves that
have been accumulating for several years
it's money that's been transferred from
our growth and efficiency fund
and these plans
are not
new core budget proposals
they are not being baked into our
long-term spending commitments and we
are not borrowing to spend
the reserves we are now spending have
risen
from our prudent and careful management
of our finances
from windfall income such as extra
planning fees and also from receipt of
new homes bonus
so these top slices of income or
one-time bonuses can now be put to great
use
for the great benefit of our residents
and although many are fully funded
one-off initiatives there are some
projects which are experimental pilot
projects with modest short-term funding
in order for us to establish their
efficacy
and if the cost benefits do prove
worthwhile then they may well be
incorporated into our longer-term
spending plans
i hope that all everyone here can see
the benefit of trialling pilot projects
this way and perhaps this goes some way
to answering councillor phil's earlier
question
now mid suffolk is and will continue to
be a low council tax district council
efficiently delivering our core funded
services whilst we also deliver these
new ambitious
and extended programs of work
to address our priorities
from this reserve spending from the
recirculating loans and from the
external match funding
and that's the cabinet room for finance
i'm pleased to back this report
to back this spending
and commend it to my fellow cabinet
members in fact to all my counsellor
colleagues and to all our residents
thank you madam chairman
thank you
anybody
else want to contribute
no
i think this
this set of proposals is
a fantastic achievement
as
as leader i get to talk to
leaders in other councils and where
most of them are tightening their belts
and cutting back on expenditure
because of the care the due diligence
and the careful planning
around our expenses over the last
at least since i've been a counsellor
um
we are in the fortunate position of
being able to help our districts grow
and recover
from this awful pandemic
and i think this is a
testament
to
all our councillors hard work our
strategic directors and corporate
managers
throughout the organization that we are
now in a position to be able to to spend
over four million pounds on supporting
our residents and our businesses
to grow and thrive
in the aftermath of this pandemic and
make no mistake
we will
see far better outcomes for both
businesses and people
as a result of what we
hopefully are going to approve today
so
thank you everybody for contributing
not only your ideas and your thoughts
in the all member workshops that took
place earlier in the summer but also
all our offices time
and
energy and enthusiasm
for for contributing this
we we have gone through these papers
so i was going to say several times many
times
more than once or twice
and each portfolio holder has had
many many detailed briefings to get us
to this position and so i'd like to
thank everybody involved in this it's a
fantastic achievement to be able to vote
on this today
so i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you everybody
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress on your app
chair that is eight votes for
thank you well done
so
that's the close of the meeting
the time is 12 58
the date and time of next meeting is
monday the 6th of december at 10 30
in the chamber thank you all very much
indeed for all your contribution
you